Đừng biến đường là mình là của mình.
Bụi và trạm trong clip dưới đây,
một lần nữa cho thấy thôi quan tuy tiện của nhiều lại sẻ.
Theo lột chất tự án toàn gió thông đường bộ,
tại nơi đường gió nhau,
giữa đường không yêu tiên với đường yêu tiên,
hoặc giữa đường nhắn với đường chính,
thì xe đi từ đường không yêu tiên,
hoặc đường nhắn,
phải nhường đường cho xe đi trên đường yêu tiên,
hoặc đường chính từ bất kỳ hướng nào tới.
Nhưng lại xe con tại tình hũng trong clip đã không tên thủ quy tắc này.
Mặc dù xe tại trên đường chính đã đi qua xe con,
nhưng lại xe con vẫn điều khiến phương tiện đâm vào phần thủ xe tại.
Ê thức tối của lại xe con,
kêu đường là đường của mình,
ngay từ khi đi từ đường nhắn ra đường chính,
đã không nhường đường cho xe trên đường chính.
Hô qua xe ra chỉ thiết hại về tại sản,
vẫn còn khá nhẹ lối với hành VV phạm của lại xe con.